Medicare enrollment is underway and to
answer your questions we're in the call
8 phone bank taking your phone calls at
702-650-1101 and joining us now to
answer your questions more questions is
Dr garisha Carr of Southwest Medical of
Optum care thanks Dr Carr for being here
first of all this is an important
decision that people have to make why is
it so important well uh you know annual
enrollment is here it started October
15th and is ongoing through December 7th
so time to evaluate your current
Medicare plans or if you're new to
Medicare so important to talk to an
insurance agent who can help you decide
what's the best plan for you yeah
because it can be complicated and each
plan has different benefits tell us
about the benefits at Optimum care well
um so if you have a Medicare Advantage
plan that is accepted by Optum then you
can have dental vision access to special
specialty which is part of the Optum
Network so a lot of access there we have
17 primary care clinics a lot of them
have urgent cares embedded so a lot of
good care what other advice can you give
people when it comes to finding the
right plan so you know everyone is
really worried about how much money they
would have to spend right so looking at
what you're out of pot out of pocket
costs can be when you are choosing a
plan so so important you know make sure
that the plan that you have is going to
cover your medications it still has your
specialist and of course your primary
care doctor all right Dr Carr thanks so
much for being with us today and
answering questions and again these
volunteers are going to be here
throughout this evening answering your
questions about Medicare enrollment
702-650-1101